you could prove that you you have an
identity in your KY seed
effectively um so again I'll just go
through the slides we're not going to go
into detail but again that that's that's
the selling point of zkps you can
automate it make it cheaper more
effective um and future
proof I think like one thing that always
happens in these presentations is people
talk about a technology that's you know
a couple of years away um you know have
to do some pilots and test this out but
I I think it's worth stressing that we
can do this today and there's enormous
benefits from actually doing this on
ethereum um if we go to the next slide I
think um for the last 8 10 years like
the whole defi industry on ethereum has
been battle tested you know yes there's
been hacks there's been issues but we
now have very robust um trading venues
such as Unis swap we have uh huge hugely
successful lending markets of a compound
um all of this infrastructure uh exists
and all it needs is real world assets
rather than kind of assets that are
derived from you know um the ethereum
kind of native currency or bridged
assets like usdc um where someone else
is kind of uh you know giving those
assets value I think like leveraging uh
ethereum's kind of legacy and all of the
things that have already been created uh
means it's the perfect place to launch
one of these currencies
let's go to summary of key takeaways um
if there's there's a few things that you
come out of this
talk um here here are the
things yeah I think I'll say this point
again um you know existing cbdc designs
especially if they're moved on chain are
a dystopia um you know they're not a
world uh that anyone I think who's who's
come to Devcon wants to live in and we
have a chance to create that Utopia but
we have to kind of put some of these
learnings uh into practice um and yeah
as I said before um we can do this today
on ethereum the technology exists um
it's been iterated on for the last you
know 3 to five years ckps are performant
enough to prove all the things that are
needed today and so we can make a much
better Financial uh
system and I think the last point I
think the first mover Advantage is
absolutely
underrated and it is a huge opportunity
for Nations
to effectively be the first and reap
asymmetric
geopolitical finan you know economic
rewards if if they launch a privacy
first cbdc on ethereum so stay tuned for
our report uh which is coming out um I
think it's next week actually and we're
very excited to have um have you know
given you some of our knowledge and our
our vision around this and very much
open to questions
I think you can uh scan the QR code for
questions maybe all right thank you you
guys so we have a Q&A session is we see
some question pop up there already all
right you guys want to start from the
the first
question uh maybe I can start and Andre
can fill in um so one of the key
requirements in kind of uh the bank of
England's kind of initial consultation
uh for its digital pound was privacy
like the the bank of England doesn't
want to know what the citizens are up to
it wants to kind of have intermediaries
that do that other other mechanisms that
kind of Ensure compliance so uh in that
case yeah the government doesn't they
expressly kind of do care about privacy
and they don't want to know um about you
know users personal information because
it leaves them open to another form of
attack yeah and just to um add to that
so part of our privacy first cbdc report
that's coming out is actually built on
the work we've done in trying to educate
the bank of England last year on how to
design a
cbdc with privacy by Design and um I
think it also ties into the second
question I think governments are
realizing they need cbdcs because the
current systems are are fallible um
they're slow they're not 24hour um and
they they want to they want to go on
chain but on their terms and we've
actually tried to educate the bank of
England on you know focusing on zkps so
that they have the best-in-class Privacy
uh By
Design do you want to take the Eurozone
one um Can individual Euro Zone members
do a cbdc uh on their own by law so um
good question um I haven't off the top
of my head I don't want to give a um an
answer because I think there there may
be some MAA issues I know that they can
um I know that they can consider doing
that obviously I mean if they're not
part of the Euro Zone if they if they
have for example their own currency and
they're not part of the Euro Zone they
would have to obviously exit the Euro
Zone to launch their own
cbdc um and then they could pass their
own laws to to enable that cbdc so again
using Montenegro as an example
Montenegro um is not part of the Euro
Zone um but if they were they would have
to leave it and even if they were to
issue a cbdc they would have to change
laws to enable the creation of a cbdc in
any case so the the bottom line is um
Can individual EUR Zone members do their
own cbdc yes because they can remove
themselves from the Euro Zone past laws
that enable
cbdc um and create their own future
effectively yeah we got uh 40 seconds
for the last one uh a little bit spicy
um very we're still working uh on Aztec
uh we pretty close to testnet um so yeah
we'll be launching kind of the first
programmable privacy Network on ethereum
um you know you could use part of that
to uh create these cbdcs um for me
personally like we get approached by a
lot of people to to work on cbdcs then I
just see it as a opportunity to not
create the dystopia like there's kind of
two paths in the road we can stay in
kind of like our our crypto Lane and
pretend that we're all going to transact
in ethereum and like these assets or we
can try and bring this technology to the
masses and you know that that's why I'm
here so uh yeah hopefully that answers
the question all right that's awesome
you guys keep that Applause for the
speakers on the stage please thank you
guys amazing SI all right let's
go all right the next session going to
start at 400 p.m. so in about
five minute okay see you guys in a bit
[Music]
remember for
I
much
[Music]
all right you guys let's go to the
second uh session for today on the St
six the second session is when P2P
electronic cast system and the speaker
is Conrad ER bans please welcome the
[Music]
speakers
hello cool who knows in which year the
peer-to-peer electronic cash system
paper came out
anyone else I'm sure you know just three
people four people okay which year was
it 2008 right so we're still waiting for
that peer-to-peer electronic cash I
think it's fair to say that we've not
taken over the peer-to-peer um payments
World um Bitcoin has definitely found
pmf product Market fit with store of
value and
um I don't want to argue that there are
no payments on bitcoin but clearly um
the last payments you've made to come
here maybe with your grab or Bol or Uber
were probably not Bitcoin or onchain
payments at
all just to show how ancient this paper
is this is 2008 right so in 2008 GTA4
came out that's how long ago this was um
the iPhone just came out a year earlier
people dressed like this I think it's
cool but also very very
ancient Bitcoin was largely well came
out right in time as a perfect reaction
to the um financial crisis of 20078 this
is how long ago it was
right I think we all he know what
peer-to peer means but let's briefly
talk about the cash part because I think
it's very easy to think of cash as
payments
but payments are not exactly cash I
would say that cash payments are a
subset of all payments and usually when
we talk about payments we talk about
something that's much much more
complicated so last time you ordered
your grab to get here um you made
probably a credit card payment with that
there was a very big bundle of service
that enabled things like
chargebacks maybe you were using a
credit card um and definitely there are
some points and rewards so I'm still
waiting for the Visa and MasterCard air
drop um but I would just want to talk
about the simplest of payments like this
very raw um payment which just goes
payer to paye without all of these
bundled um services so this is what we
usually mean by cash payment right like
if I give give a 100 bats to a taxi
driver there's no way to charge back
unless I hunt him down somehow um there
also no points or um and there's
definitely not a credit
system so for today I'd briefly like to
talk about why why we haven't taken over
the world yet and what's needed to take
over the world with unchain payments um
so I'll give a mini intro about myself
and then we'll go through a mini history
just to honor our ancestors and then
I'll talk through five narratives that
were popular um or that are popular to
answer like this is the blocker like we
can't have payments because of I don't
know scalability let's say right so
these will be the five um topics that
we'll
analyze so about me um I'm the peut
brain at peanut protocol um you can look
me up here and and also DM me here
um so let's go and honor our ancestors I
think I think it's really important to
realize the first wave of
blockchains um and and categorize these
uh very briefly so we had Bitcoin which
I already mentioned and then we had a
bunch of payments projects that that
were strictly about this cash element
strictly about making payments happen so
I think Litecoin fits that uh category
very very well and dash definitely does
stellar I would say too um then we had
private payments mon own zcash um the
only ones with smart contracts are next
and ethereum uh by the
way so despite all of these huge
ecosystems well some of them huge
ecosystems we haven't yet moved um cash
or payments on chain
so um when I was prepping for this talk
I had the honor to talk to some of these
ancestors and people who are working on
these very ancient projects and I asked
them like how are you going about trying
to boot trp your payment Network and um
one of the guys I talked to he was
running a campaign in
2017 trying to convince parking garages
and um like very local shops in one
local city in the US to adopt their
their coin um as one of the payment
methods as you might guess it's quite a
hopeless endeavor because you not only
have to convince the garages but also
you have to convince all the drivers to
adopt your thing in an ecosystem where
there is the dollar already and people
are used to coins and and dollar nodes
so what's the advantage of bootstrapping
that one token one chain thing I think
quite similarly we have um who's been at
ECC this
year nice cool you might have seen the
payments Cafe by Bas they were selling
cappuccinos
um where you could just take your
coinbase wallet and just just just make
a payment for your capuccino and there I
wondered well isn't it the same case
what's my reason to switch over from
that like opening up my wallet and so on
when I'm so used to just tapping my card
right um especially that was just usdc
on base with which you could
pay so here are the candidates one
common narrative will be scalability so
we need fast and cheap for transactions
I'll kind of argue against that then
another one is privacy I think highly
important in a world where we have full
adoption and most payments happen um on
chain but I will also argue that we can
have a world um where settlement happens
on chain
but and and stuff is still reasonably
private then another argument that is
very common is well payments are not on
chain yet um or haven't captured a whole
like payments um Market in trafi because
um stable coins are relatively new I'll
also argue against that um and then
finally um for the uh 4337 Mafia um um
one common argument is hey we need
better account management we have to
have account abstraction all these like
nice ux um improvements I will also say
well that's not the
like the main blocker here and then
finally we'll go into the interrupt
thesis so let's start I think this is a
very common thing um especially in the
early days of blockchains this was a
very very common thing to hear in when
people were were pitching l1's but also
still l2s right so the pitch goes
something like this in order to compete
with trafi payments we have to be
similarly cheap and fast so Visa has
24,000 um TPS and my blockchain is so
much faster it is 69,000 um TP PS right
um I think I think again this kind of
it's a bad comparison because you're
comparing these very raw payments of
just transferring value from A to B with
Visa which is this very very complex
very bundled um payment solution and
then also perhaps more importantly for
the argument here is there should be a
subset of payments where this doesn't
matter right so if I do a $1 million
transaction and there are hundreds of
thousands of these happening every day
or Millions maybe even well definitely
Millions then it shouldn't matter
whether I'm you know using Bitcoin um
which is slow and relatively expensive
but by the way what do you think what
are current bitcoin fees today if I want
to send $1 million um to another country
what's the fee on Bitcoin in dollars any
guesses
yeah
$1 yeah that's not much you can't do
that in trifire you can't send a million
dollars to another country um uh um with
one Buck you can't you can't do that not
in that order of magnitude right so
clearly there should be some subset of
payments where um where it would be more
efficient to already use Bitcoin
something as simple as Bitcoin as the
kind of international settlement thing
this is especially true for um rare
International pairs where normally you
would be doing many hops between Banks
so the way a traf International payment
works is you you're sending kind of
they're exchanging these IUS and they
have these um very custom agreements
between each other to trust each other
with these IUS so when you're sending
let's say money from Armenia to Chile um
it might very well be the case that this
payment is going to do five or six hops
across the world so first to a more
local bank and then to another one maybe
then to some US bank and then finally to
some Latin bank and then finally um to
Chile in the meantime you don't know
where the payment is and the fees you
don't know how how much each
intermediary is going to collect so
already this should be more even with
Bitcoin something as primitive as
Bitcoin like V1 of blockchains um it
should be more efficient but guess what
here's my startup idea right why don't
we do a transfer wise um but with
Bitcoin rails right so the way transfer
wise works is you have these these bank
accounts in different countries and then
they kind of just internally settle um
the payment so they front it for you
they receive it in one country then they
front it to you in in the other country
well here's the problem for that to
happen you would need two Banks to agree
not to ban you for your Bitcoin payments
right
so if you can convince two Banks not to
ban you um because you're not fitting
their AML requirements or they don't
know what you're doing or just scared of
Bitcoin or they think it's like some
shady thing then you might as well just
have a normal very classical IOU type
contract with these guys to just do a
normal settlement so if you've
identified this pair where there's a lot
of sudden trade happening um and it's
not been captured yet let's say I don't
know um Chileans suddenly get obsessed
about Ethiopian coffee if if suddenly
there's a lot of trade happening
immediately there will be some some
someone who will try to capture those
flows to avoid all these inefficiencies
with these hops right um and you can do
so with IUS for these large transactions
so this very convincing narrative on
like when you hear it for the first time
oh yeah sure let's use crypto rails for
the for just for the international part
is actually maybe not as uh strong for
these like larger B2B transactions
especially when it comes to Global
Supply chains cool another narrative
privacy well we can't have like we can't
penetrate a whole Market unless we have
privacy obviously if I um go somewhere
and I buy my coffee I don't want to
broadcast that to literally the entire
world that I just bought um a pumpkin
spice latte right that's extremely
embarrassing and I don't want other
people to know um I think well again um
that does not much for the just rails
thesis because you could have some kind
of company that wraps Monero or zcash or
some other solution and makes it into a
nice um payment thing but also so you
could just obus skate using centralized
means right and that hasn't popped up
yet we've not truly challenged payments
um uh that way so I don't think that's
the main blocker okay another very very
common one so stable coins very very hot
topet fit mostly as collateral for defi
stuff right they haven't necessarily or
at least early on they haven't found pmf
for payments we haven't seen that much
action in terms of um St coin payments
it's changing now I think there's this
emerging very n uh stable coin payments
Market which is extremely exciting um
but that's also not uh the main blocker
for these for the crypto rail thesis
because I mean if I'm just using it for
one hop so I'm I'm I'm selling my my
whatever Polo lotes here and then
sending them over
to um Brazil then like it's just one hop
over Bitcoin the next block I'm already
selling it so the the the
fluctuation of the value doesn't matter
too
much um and also it's just false that
you can't make payments with a highly
volatile currency right like hundreds of
countries have or dozens of countries
have highly volatile currencies and yet
somehow people get paid and and have
salaries and so on
um so another thesis accounts right so
here are the ideas that we need
something like account abstraction for
Mass
adoption um better onboarding stuff like
account recovery more granular
permissions I mean if you think about it
like it's kind of crazy that but again
there should be some subset of payments
where all of this doesn't matter because
we do have um these professionalized
custodians we can have like for for
larger uh B2B payments we could have um
all of that so what's needed to
unlock these payments for everyone to
have this pure to- pure cash that is
fully on chain so I'd like to argue that
it's as simple as interoperability with
everything else so um I mentioned early
on this guy who was going around garages
trying to convince them hey adopt or a
coin for parking um fees and
unfortunately they weren't very
successful well because it didn't it
wasn't interoperable with standard ways
of paying for parking right um so here's
the thesis interoperability is necessary
it's a necessary condition for
interchangeability which makes what
money is which makes money be spendable
um which in turn is a necessary
condition for any new payment Network so
essentially the idea of bootstrapping a
whole payment network from scratch that
won't work right
so what does this mean in practice so um
um I have coins on scroll but I want to
pay on Tao what do I do um super
annoying if I want usdc 10 usdc
on optimism U Want 10 USD on arbitrum
super
annoying um another one is um maybe I
have some stable coins but you want Fiat
um that's a problem we recently um asked
like how we could solve that and this is
what I mean by interoperability so
making it such that it's not one chain
one token but any chain any token and
even Fiat crypto
right so um we have a November challenge
which is the No Sex uh challenge to
avoid using um centralized exchanges for
a whole month um yeah if you want to uh
hit me up I can share the details um
later um but back to the this idea how
can we how can we achieve this
interoperability well it's really really
hard because blockchain not all
blockchains talk to each other uh very
well um and also Fiat and crypto doesn't
talk to each other very well so there
needs to be some layers of abstraction
that let all of this get routed um
correctly and I think one approach is um
to lock up the funds and then let them
be routed where they need to go and this
is something we've been researching for
the past um one and a half
years um but also I'd like to very
briefly mention that um it might be the
case is that payments are currently
being eaten by visa and MasterCard
crypto payments are being eaten um by
that because there's this huge emergence
of cards of crypto cards which I'm using
too by the way uh I think they're
extremely convenient and a great tool um
but we also need to ask ourselves well
maybe we can maybe we can skip that step
right um maybe we can somehow uh be
interoperable in such a way that the
merchant receives um this raw simple
payment without all of these um extra
things like um the rewards points
chargebacks because not for all payment
types there are needed right so maybe we
need to unbundle the payment a little
bit
um as one of the final notes I'd like to
this is a quote I F found when I was
researching for this um for this
presentation and it's from
2014 um and this was from someone from
the Bitcoin foundation and essentially
she said um that you can send money over
the
Internet um for which is super useful
for especially the unbanked right so
maybe the it's it's really interesting
for me to see that this was the
narrative 10 years ago and still um it's
a really really important part of what
we're doing um so to summarize we have
briefly discussed scalability where we
discovered that um for some subset of P
payments it shouldn't matter um but if
it doesn't matter for these payments you
need these um Banks to any way agree
then you might as well um go directly
through the banks and not use the crypto
rails right we've discovered the
benefits of account abstraction and easy
onboarding for like a mass payment um we
briefly discussed stable coins and what
role they could play in the payment
space then we briefly discuss privacy
and the needs that like is it going to
happen um and then finally um we
discussed what interoperability means on
a technical level but I'd also like to
briefly touch on the regulatory level
where um essentially by having
regulatory Clarity we can convince more
and more of these trafi um institutions
to be well interoperable with um our
payment
systems so so yeah long story short I
strongly believe that the next
generation of banks um will simply skip
the Neo Bank stage so if you
interoperable with try yeah um if you
want to talk payments uh if you want to
exchange memes please DM me uh these are
my details um yeah open to
questions all right okay and now we come
to the Q&A session you guys the QR code
on the screen any question for for the
speaker please scan okay here we go man
the first one
coming all right what are your thought
on agents using stable Co for online
purchases and agents agent to agent just
the dep thing I guess human payments
let's go
yes let's do it I mean uh I think I
think you know the idea of intense is
much much broader than um just intents
for a swap or a cross-chain swap um
intents can be you know just um orders
for something and I can just Express
something like hey I want a pizza for so
for so and so many Bitcoin um and
someone should be able to go around the
world um whether that's um a human or an
auton
auton well a bot um or AI agent um and
solve that for me right um I think I
think that's um clearly something that
will happen um where all these searches
will be done by
bods all right we have a second question
second question is uh privacy a blocker
for widespread adoption yes but also um
we don't have widespread adoption yet
right so if you think about your
payments that you've made probably this
week you've made several dozen payments
uh for coffees Ubers U maybe to a
landlord maybe you've received a salary
um that were not on chain and um and
privacy yeah simply it's too small of a
percentage of payments to matter um in a
big way so I think it will be a huge
problem and will be blocker but just not
yet um and we have a path forward right
like we we we know how to at least have
soft privacy without getting jailed um
more questions coming all right there's
a third one there how important is uh
financial literacy I think hugely
important in emergent economies right so
um if you think about emergent economies
the the financial products that they
have access to um that people have
normal people have access to are
extremely primitive a lot of people are
still saving their um salaries in
dollars rather than I don't know
something like the S&P 500 or ethereum
um and and they simply don't have access
to more sophisticated Financial products
um all of this will need a lot of
Education um but for now I think also we
can make uh more sophisticated Financial
products accessible um to emerging
economies through
crypto I have the fourth question can
monopolies do anything well I'm yeah I'm
I'm that's that's a very very good
question I think um the the main
challenge right now is that um Vis and
MasterCard have a very very lucrative
reward system which the uh Merchants pay
for right so if you think about a credit
card payment versus a debit card payment
if you're using a credit card and you're
getting like some cash back or some
other rewards um you're essentially
getting subsidized by all the people who
paid um in cash um or with a debit card
I think that's a cycle that's very very
hard um to break and that's why I think
the first um
widespread um onchain payment system
will emerge in emerging economies where
penetration of visa and MasterCard isn't
that high and we will have to build our
own um similar reward system maybe you
know maybe some Crypton native um
distribution methods like um Future air
drops and stuff like that might be a
very good way to bootstrap a payments
Network and we have one minute left for
the Q&A so maybe we can get a this two
or three question yeah go ahead sure so
what specific domains or use cases for
payments do you think are most promising
in the near term I think um we have this
incredible explosion of remote work and
Global work and Global teams in crypto
um almost well the majority of teams is
is is somehow globally distributed
payments are frankly a pain and about to
manage I think um we will see um uh a
huge emergence of um onchain payments
that then use some kind of localized um
off ramps um yeah what this is the last
question what yeah uh at what level is
adoption oh super low like I mean we
don't know right we don't know but um
because it's very hard to to estimate
but I mean it's it's definitely Sub sub
1% and and um if you account for all
payments and definitely and probably sub
Z . 1%
um all right all right thank you you
guys so much Applause to the urban
[Applause]
please the next session going to start
in 4 minute and you don't want to miss
this the next session guys see you in a
[Music]
bit for
oh e
[Music]
m
for
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right let's go to the third session
ask question first anyone here no P
apps are you guys know who's coming next
we have the inventory of the poabs here
with you guys so the session going to be
the anatomy of web 3 startup please
welcome Peto with holler let's go
[Music]
good afternoon everyone thank you very
much for coming I know you have plenty
of options and you are very appreciated
for being here and for listening what
I'm going to present this is my sixth
Devcon I think I didn't miss anyone
since SE and it's the first time I speak
so it feels pretty great um the content
I have prepared I prepared very
carefully so let's get into
it um when I was thinking what's the
best content I can bring to Devcon I
thought well my work at poop for the
past five years has been pretty intense
and has exposed me to somewhat
impossible to learn of it like in in
startups you learned my doing so I was
like yeah I'm going to I'm going to
share what I've done so these are some
little ballot points
um one of my personality traits is that
I'm um extremely up front about how I
think so this is why the first type item
is offering and filter firstand
information of how to fil when a web
startup um especially the painful Parts
um I'm not here to sell you yeah I run a
startup and things are going to be fine
more like the opposite then um as part
of our experience um I want to make
clear what's different on the web3
ecosystem than the two than the web two
ecosystems running a startups is
extremely painful in all ecosystems but
web3 has several specific types of pain
so I want to cover some of them
and after all
that pretty frightening information I
want to present I want to still make
clear that for
certain uh type of people not only it is
worth trying it is what makes sense
doing so we you will see
why um a quick intro about me although I
am
seeing most of those that I'm seeing I
know you and you know me but you may get
some tidbits that you didn't know um I
am 37 I live most of my life in
butis being rais in buen oitis has
shaped my personality pretty specific
speically so so it's a major piece of
information Argentina has a very deep
crypto tradition and that has given me a
privilege view specifically for what
crypto is useful for what's not useful
for um so so that's that's a key part of
how I got to work with what I am um up
until 2015 um I had a pretty average
Shob as a computer repair person I was a
computer technician um in 2015
um I was pretty fed up with my lifestyle
I wasn't happy how I was doing so I was
seeking for a change um I was already
somewhat into Bitcoin and I was like
yeah I'm going to go full time on this
so I went fulltime into ethereum
ethereum was an emerging technology that
it was really hard to understand way
harder than it is today and I spend the
next three years 2015 16 17 18 um
learning about etherium um and and again
it was a pretty steep learning cure I'm
a high school dropout so I'm not a
computer technician or any of those
super
fancy um educated uh etherum people and
by
2018 um not only I have achieved
diminishing returns
in um what I could learn but also the
ecosystem was in a pretty unpleasant
situation 20 18 was right after the Ico
Bubble Burst and an eum was in a very
ugly bottom um prices were coming down
DBS weren working the road map wasn't
coming together so that takes us to our
next slide on which I plan on explaining
quickly why in 2018 I I started
ethereum um in 2018 I gathered a couple
friends and I convinc them on building
an application on ethereum that can do
something that you couldn't do with any
other technology that was for me a way
to show that eum wasn't just the
technology for speculating with
financial assets or for gambling or for
criminal activities there could be
things that you could build with
programmable
blockchains that really solve problems
that people have better than any other
technology and one obvious problem back
then and still today is that these days
in our digital lifestyle we don't owe
nothing um all the information in your
iPhones or Android devices and in many
computers it's stored on the cloud and
you're subject to certain policies and
you don't have ownership of that
information and it's very common that if
it's no longer a business for your
provider to to serve it or host it they
will shut it down or they will change
the terms or or they will start
churching you and one platform that's
been subject to this issues was for
square for square was a a web CH app
that you had in your phone and when you
went to a bar or a restaurant you
checked in and you got a little
collectible now the little collectible
wasn't on a blockchain it wasn't yours
and when Forks Square decided to change
their business model people that had
thousands of Collectibles were left in
the dark so I was like why don't we
build an ethereum application on which
these little Collectibles are nfts and
because they Meed on a blockchain they
are immutable and you have them forever
and they have all the qualities that
nfts have like like authenticity and um
provenance and several other things that
don't really come to mind so we start
building this and it goes pretty well um
we launch in 2019
well I have explained this already I
mess up the um the order of the
slides um so that that's the little
intro of Po by the way there's going to
be a PO up at the end of the talk so you
better get your apps ready and some
other house picking stuff that's Prett
fun now this
um this way of coming up with the idea
of pup I would have
wanted to show that ethereum was useful
technology that makes sense
brings us what it's the most obvious
early organs of a company which is the
idea and how to finance it if if we were
analyzing major companies companies has
plenty of organs like legal and HR and
revenue sales purchasing Etc but in an
early startup you pretty much have
someone the founder or a group of
Founders that have an ideas and ideas
are extremely cheap like like there are
time do so ideas are pretty much worth
nothing but when you match an idea um
with a little source of financing at
least enough for the founder to come by
then you start having the Embry onary
situation of an early startup and this
is mostly what I want to what I want to
call to cover today because um we could
talk about the whole the whole day start
about the startups but in the web three
space we've been seeing and we continue
to see extremely exotic ways of
financing because of tokens and the
possibility of creating crazy
speculative
mechanisms and although some of these
mechanism for fin financing companies
are fascinating and
awesome they
are at the same time what make
a starting a web tree company pretty
much a suicidal Mission um there's only
a handful of cases of
successful startups that had completed
the cycle that started with an idea with
some little financing and that
eventually completed a cycle and have
become successful sustainable profitable
business most of the crypto companies
these days big and small are running on
either extremely handwavy models or they
have launched tokens and they are still
somewhat holding up or maybe they are
holding up really well but normal
business that check the boxes of a
business that makes sense I'm not sure I
can count to 10
so I was talking about the different
models of financing and of course we are
going to talk about uh tokens but let's
get um first to the easier ones to
explain
um bootstrapping web3 startup um it's a
model of financing that I recommend a
lot this is pretty much the founder of
the founding teams running it with their
own money not taking external capital
and seeing how they could do it and this
is a very valid model um many Founders
um work full-time at something else and
then they render a start up on the side
and only after validating whatever idea
they had or finding enough track ction
they decide to transition to something
else that's not bu strapping so bu
strapping um it's really easy to explain
is pretty much not taking external
funding the founder Carise the burden of
figuring out how to pay the bills and
the bills in web startup are extremely
expensive for a bunch of reasons that we
don't have time to cover then um there's
another alternative for financing and we
aren going to talk much about them
because I don't think in this day and
age it makes sense but it's traditional
VC um traditional VC it's an extremely
developed uh
model it's been running for more than 20
years there are thousands of VC
companies but in
practice and and this is an unpopular
opinion but traditional VC has nothing
to do with crypto um crypto startups
have a degree of uncertainty that just
doesn't fit the model of traditional
Venture Capital traditional Capital has
some um formulas and and um some models
and time frames
and many companies have
applied in crypto I don't think it has
ever worked I don't think it will ever
work the only crypto companies that are
financed by traditional ventor Capital
are pretty much not Crypt native
companies like they could be
custodian um custodians or financing
services or compliance or legal or KC
that kind of V maybe could qualify by
traditional BC um but in my personal
opinion um if you are building a
business that qualifies for traditional
Venture Capital uh go for it the content
I'm presenting here might not be too
useful for you um but surely the point I
want to make clear if you are a Crypton
native company building a crypto native
business model it's highly unlikely that
traditional Venture Capital works for
you and traditional B may want to
believe that it could work you are going
to waste your time and now I'm going to
skip for a second uh crypto Venture
Capital because that's the
hardest um the hardest one to grow and
explain and I'm going to explain the
grants and exotic financing um because
that's underexplored and it's a very
viable model for aspiring Founders these
days aspiring Founders these days when
they have an idea um they have pretty
much the three options I mentioned
bootstrapping which is probably not
viable unless they have lots of money or
some money um crypto Venture Capital
which I don't recommend unless they're
extremely sure what they are doing and
then there's this Grand s financing gr
and exotic financing means there's
plenty of organizations in crypto that
have more more money than what they know
how to spend this can be Dows they can
be foundations they can be individuals
and there are plenty of individuals
there are plenty of whales that you may
meet at a conference or in a hallway or
in a local Meetup and you present an
idea and you're like yeah if I had
$50,000 I could build this this and this
and this happens more often than not
there are even some success stories of
companies that is starring out of Grants
or this kind of financing and have grown
to eventually raising Millions from BC
so Grant sting financing it's a very
valid and very
honorable um way of raising capital for
an early web3 startup that I absolutely
recommend and then and I left it for the
uh last um item on the four models that
I presented is traditional Crypt VC
unfortunately traditional Crypt
VC has evolved naturally I don't think
anyone specifically wanted to go that
way
in a perverted
model of um greater
fools there are plenty of Highly skilled
with plenty of social skills and
abilities
investors that are meeting founders with
ideas in need of financing and they will
convince them or they will promote them
and help them do a token Finance comp
company and that's pretty much a dead
sentence
it's a minimal chance of long-term
sustainable success that a Founder uh
get when they sign a deal with a VC that
expects a token there are so many highly
competed mechanisms that start to play
that even if the business makes sense
and it grows and it checks all the boxes
they typically burn the founder out um
Founders burn out it's a a pretty
pervasive um condition in this industry
and tokens make everything a 100 times
harder so um
my recommendation is that first time
Founders avoid BC even if you believe
your idea is crypto VC even if you
believe your idea is
great um only puru crypto VC if you have
a solid plan that really checks the
boxes and doesn't have the classical
hand
wavy um um models like yeah we are going
to race here and we are going to ship
this and eventually we are going to
launch a token and the token price will
pump enough that we are going to have uh
so much money to continue Building
without worrying about Runway that's a
success stories for BCS and I don't
blame them but it's this thing that I
call it a suicidal model and a Deb
centers for Founders um eventually the
model um of Crypt BC when the regulatory
landscape gets better may have a second
shot and it would work but in this
context on which tokens Can Do profit
sharing or any kind of Revenue sharing
or tokenized Equity
um
everything token govern whatever or
utility token or all those things they
are ill fate they are not worth pursuing
and it breaks my heart I met some uh
some Founders this week I I I've done in
my career
over 200 Investments so I must have I
must have talked with a thousand
Founders it breaks my heart when I meet
a Founder with a good idea full of
enthusiasm that is about to sign a term
sheet and do pretty much this Devil's
pack that's going to drain their energy
um so again my
recommendation is unless you are
extremely sure and well advised and well
contained on what you're what you are
signing up for just
chill and continue your crypto Journey
because right now the ecosystem and
everything around is such a mindfield
that your chances of survival are so
little that the trade of the the risk
reward ratio is not worth it um now I
don't have much time so I will come up
with a couple before the questions with
a couple house shipping items um I plan
on doubling down on the contents of this
talk in an upcoming conference I don't
know which one is going to be um but
hopefully what comes next after this we
will cover sometime in
2025 um of course I'm I'm very keen on
answering questions but I also want you
to know that because you came and listen
to all this rant that I had prepared um
you're going to be part of a pup that we
will all share and that poop can be
minted um using two mechanisms one it's
a secret word that you just Ty in the PO
up and that secret word is collectibl
the other one if you don't have the PO
up is that QR code which I'm going to
try to scan now if you don't
mind this poab can only be minted while
we are here it looks like mine is
minting um but then there's going to be
another pup uh for those that are
watching the live stream or the
recording which is going to be for sale
for 01 e or something with the proceeds
going to the nonprofit Foundation it's
taker so I'm going to get to that slide
and I'll leave it for a few
seconds um this is called an Airship uh
and it explains where to set the funds
and the PO that you will get and some
other fun stuff this is not particularly
for you to it is mostly so it is on
video and the last housekeeping item
which is a fun New Louch that we are
doing uh
today it's a GPS minting it's a way for
minting a power bound to a geographical
location this one is
configured um for anyone that's on the
range of 7 kilomet from this venue so I
encourage everyone to do the scan
location button in the PowerUp get that
really fun PowerUp and hopefully one one
of the all the mins randomly picked um
is going to win one e um so with that I
think we can move up to the
questions all right awesome awesome
let's go to the you guys we have the QR
code on the on your right side and send
him the question whatever you have
question for him and you ready for the
question I am all right let's go
so we can have so many question here and
if you already have some question that
people ask for that you can just upboard
it anyone I mean he did really great
presentation right there's no question
for him at
all all right don't be shy yeah and and
you guys have the PAB apps don't forget
to use the scan the location and you can
get the p app like from Bangkok here
right yeah yeah and of course I'm
planning on being around the venue um so
if whatever you want to talk send a
question can you send a question through
this one so people can can see the
question too so you can use the the
camera to scan this and you send the
question through the
screen is that
working all right one second maybe we
can get oh my
okay his microphone's right
here oh who want to ask a question see
that guy
okay uh just a logistical thing how do
you choose um like how do you do the
randomness of the function to pick the
winner of the one if like is it chain
link is it onchain are you using any
hand I love this question uh you know
why I love it because we have worked
really hard for the system to be
probabbly verifiable um we didn't want
this to be like yeah he has one so we
use a product called uh po. fun po. fun
is an open source software it's not set
up yet you can check it out but it's an
open source software um on which um the
system gets all the poops ID and those
IDs are tickets for a raffle and at a
given time there is a little super basic
formula um that uses the gas usage of a
series of log and when the number the
gas usage matches the hash or the number
of whatever the ticket was um that's how
it makes a leaderboard and I think it it
does like knock down system so it's it
goes knocking down people and the last
standing winner gets a price um we
specifically wanted this system to be
probably verifiable and credibly neutral
because otherwise why could we do it at
all all right we have like a lot of
question so we have about 2 minute a
little bit so let's pick a few question
question you can see that here yeah how
to ask to the visitor ask for token I
think if you don't have a very good
answer for why your product needs a
token you have nothing to do with tokens
and you just have to accept that you
shouldn't take funding from that BC and
this is extremely painful but I am uh
pretty
straightforward you don't need to work
with BCS that uh want the token even if
means that you cannot run your startup
if your startup cannot be run without a
token if you cannot get financing
without a token you probably shouldn't
push you it um tokens are useless not at
all tokens are a fascinating
coordination instrument I expect tokens
to create a revolution in human
coordination at a scale it's just that
in this day and age with the regulatory
constraints you cannot use tokens as
means of
financing um what are the best
unconventional ways a Founder can fund
race for an idea or an MVP they have um
the easy ones it's a larger the larger
THS of el like carb mon optimism and
there are many more mantel it's another
good one they have huge amounts of money
they AR afraid of spending if you have
an idea you just need to come up with a
minimal expression of it something that
can be built with 50,000 100,000 200,000
and if the idea is good they will love
funding it uh you didn't tell the story
of how po was funded oh this is not a
secret I funded it myself uh po when po
raised money for the first time I was
already several million dollars down in
in uh in spending and even after we
raise VC money I continue thinking more
and more money it's impossible to run a
company that doesn't have a to toen and
and goes at the speed of web tree
without a really deep pocket uh so so
again this is something that needs to be
known for an aspiring founder we have
one more ex expensive we have one more
extrait for you so we people have a lot
of questions so we have one more minute
extra for you guys thank you um when po
tokens we have no plans for the token um
if the real landscape changes a lot
maybe one day we reconsider it but it
doesn't look like it's
changing
um what's the business model of poab
poab has two sources of revenue um one
it's Enterprise Partnerships uh we have
plenty of companies uh that hire us for
helping them do preal Collectibles this
company services is like Mercedes-Benz
American Express Porsche Goldman Sachs
Swift and hundreds others and similarly
uh we also make money by individuals
that buy their mid Lings and they pay
$25 per 100 pups and that's working
pretty well the market is really small
there's like 10,000 people in crypto
that can appreciate PowerUp well so we
don't make that much money with that um
but we expect this model to scale very
nice once the market picks up um are an
a good option yes definitely anent
investors are in the category of exotic
funding so I certainly like that um
follow me on Twitter to see when we do
the chapter two of this talk and I will
be happy to dig deeper specifically on
the things that you want me to talk
about thank you very much all right
thank you so much the next question
going to start in a few minute at 5:00
right see you gu in a bit
[Music]
that
we found a hotel card room here it's
Lodge 61 the room number 708 if you want
drop your card here I want you to go
back to hotel and can enter the room all
right so we're going to keep it on the
uh in the front here at a stop of you
lost your hotel key card right guys
[Music]
right all right
all right let's go to the fourth session
of the STA six today and the topic is
how web3 and rwa unlock exponential
wealth via computable economies the
speaker are jasen pots and Justin banon
please welcome the speakers
[Music]
hi everyone um so we're here to talk to
you today about the computable economy
and real world assets and um how this
can unlock um exponential
wealth
okay um so my name is Justin Bannon and
uh I'm a found found ER of uh a couple
of real world asset protocols boson
protocol and also feron
protocol yeah hi everyone I'm Jason pots
um founder of the blockchain Innovation
Hub at rmit University in Melbourne and
a crypto
Economist so the talk we're going to
give today is based on uh academic paper
that we wrote earlier this year on the
computable
economy so to start if we look at the
and we go back say to the Stone Age we
see this um pretty significant um growth
in human wealth and if we if we zoom in
a bit on that uh
uptick what you see is in the last 3 or
400 years this real strong exponential
growth in in human wealth and the
question is what's caused
that yeah so um what we want to do is to
tell a story of how economies have
evolved and what this means for you know
what crypto is bringing into this story
and we we've got a we've got a narrative
that argues that we are going through a
revolution at the moment of a very
origin of wealth um the standard story
we know about this is new technologies
so you know once upon a time this was
fire and then you know steel and steam
and and and you know we gradually worked
their way through a sort of sequence of
hundreds and thousands of you know new
Industrial Technologies that gave us the
modern economy and that's you know
that's the story of long run economic
growth is is fundamental new Industrial
Technologies but there's a second sort
of technology that is often overlooked
and it's it's this is the one that we
want to sort of try and um help you to
understand here and this is the
technology of
Institutions um institutions are a
coordination technology um the very
first one that fundamentally gave us
modern economies um 7,000 years ago was
writing writing enables people who don't
know each other to coordinate in space
and time by you know recording facts
about who owns what or whose cow is that
or who who's who owes me some honey and
that sort of beginning of writing um you
know 7,000 years ago as the beginning of
history and modern economies um First
Institutional technology was a
revolution in terms of human human
welfare um what other big instit tional
Technologies we've had um joint stock
company 14th century 15th century um
created the idea of sort of organization
of of of the corporate form to gather
resources together um we've had
institutions in timekeeping and so on
with universal clocks um working their
way through we've had Revolutions in um
in in democracy and sort of
recordkeeping of of of ownership and
identity and other sorts of fundamental
protocols but this the story that we
have is
that Industrial Technologies or
technological change you fundamentally
driven driven by research and
development um is is the main
explanation for that that hockey stick
rise but the reason it keeps going up
the reason we keep getting new and new
levels of of of of of growth is
that these sort of institutional
Technologies provide sort of languages
and coordination mechanisms to to to to
create new generations of coordination
technology and what we are going through
now the sort of the the crypto
Revolution that's being powered up by Ai
and all of these other digital
Technologies is a fundamental new type
of economy um we've called it a
computable economy um we distinguish
this from an industrial economy where
all the fundamental institutions of an
industrial economy were done by
government um in terms of recordkeeping
in terms of you know fundamental asset
Registries and the money and so on um so
this idea of this is where're up to now
in terms of a new um institutional
technological Revolution to create a new
type of economy that fundamentally Works
digitally fundamentally Works globally
um we haven't seen a revolution like
this for for hundreds of years um that's
the nature of the sort of technological
change we're seeing now the the sort of
the way we want to frame this is this
sort of computable economy Revolution
which is an Institutional technology
Revolution made possible by a series of
other Technologies you know computers
and so on um what is going on is this is
a continuation of the evolution of
compute in the universe um we described
the evolution of economies in beginning
you know beginning sort of 7,000 years
ago through to the present as the series
of Step changes as we moved up the in
the institutional technology stack from
written language through to to to
coordination so on all the way through
that process has been going on for
millions and billions of years and the
the way to think about this is that
every so often on The evolutionary
trajectory we get these huge
breakthroughs these fundamental shifts
in terms of the underlying sort of
language um of of of evolution um
evolutionary um biologists call these
meta you know meta system Transitions
and the idea is is that a digital
economy is the latest phase of a meta of
a metasystem transition where we're able
to finally sort of start to write um all
of the things in an economy um into to
be able to sort of interact with each
other now what that
means um is that the the where we are
now in terms of evolutionary um in terms
of the evolution of economies in terms
of institutional evolution is it and
this idea of economies um are not like
you know economies have computers in
them but fundamentally economies are
computers they're they're ways of
Computing sort of resources together um
to create economic value markets do that
um organizations do that protocols and
platforms do that as well and the sort
of the next step in terms of how
economies are going to develop and
evolve is to really sort of push what we
can do with that with that compute level
Justin so if we if we unpack um the
nature of this computable economy let's
first look at computers so I mean
computers will transmit store and
receive data in a highly reliable way um
and and computers will also run programs
so if you if you run the the program 1
plus one it will always equal two and
because of this sort of reliability and
the the deter you can build highly
complex applications on top of them and
if you look at this you know our modern
sort of uh internet and and digital
economy that's that sort of evidence of
that
however if we look at at sort of today's
economy um what we find is that if we
want to sort of transmit value um often
what we have to do is transmit via
intermediaries like banks for example
and the these intermediaries introduce
um sort
of risk of default they introduce fees
they're slow um and also you know if you
want to sort of store materal retrieve
value we have the have the similar
problems and so also when you want to
run economic Pro uh programs on on uh
the current economy we do this by having
a contract so let's say you know you you
have a contract with someone to provide
a service and they don't provide that
service what do you do well you have to
take them to court this is slow it's
expensive and it's fuzzy so instead of
having this sort of deterministic and
reliable substrate we have sort of a
fuzzy unreliable substrate and that
really limits the complexity of
applications that you can build on top
um and our claim is that with a with a a
computable economy when we're building
an economy on this fundamentally more
reliable substrate of of blockchains you
get some properties that are much closer
to a computer than today's economy so
you know smart contracts can enable the
transmission of value in a in a very
reliable way
um when we want to store and receive
value it's possible to do this in a way
that is reliable but that requires a
particular type of of of uh uh procedure
for tokenizing uh these assets and we'll
we'll get into that in a second but it
is possible to do that and so um with
with this kind of combination of
properties it's possible to run economic
programs on a blockchain substrate that
give this kind of reliability and
determining ISM that that you that you
don't get within today's economy and the
result of that is enabling much greater
complexity to be built upon this this
substrate um so here's our claim is that
you know blockchain technology enables a
new computable economy and unlocks
exponential wealth through increased
complexity but the condition is that
we've got to tokenize all forms of
capital all assets with with the same
strong commitments um and so we mean by
strong commitments are that you know all
the assets that we tokenize and bring on
train on chain need to be uh trust
minimized secure and verifiable
ownership and enforced by cryptography
um and so you know most assets the the
current onchain assets have these
properties inherently and there are many
many assets from things like debt Equity
that where they can be transferred
entirely on chain and we will then have
these these kind of properties of strong
commitments but there are always a class
of assets that will have a physical
residue physical assets and these can't
entirely be um represented on
chain so there's a couple of problems
with physical assets one is this
physical asset Oracle problem so if I
tokenize my car and you buy the token
how can you be sure that you'll actually
get the car and then this kind of fair
exchange problem of of how how do we
ensure that the exchange that's happened
is is fair and the quality in terms
agreed um and so you'll find there are a
number of generic um solutions for
tokenizing physical assets so the first
one is this kind of centralized model
where you will have a trusted entity um
that will that will hold the assets um
and issue a token the problem with this
is it has exactly the same problems as
the as the today's economy where we're
trusting centralized entities and that
doesn't have sufficient reliability for
for us to kind of have have this kind of
computable economy and then there are
there are two other methods so one is
where you lock up funds um and and for
for this uh method it's very transaction
cost efficient because a protocol can
just lock up the funds at very very low
cost but it's Capital inefficient um and
so this tends to work for sort of low to
medium Val Val items that you would
usually use someone like Amazon or Ebay
for um but it wouldn't work for very
high value items um and then secondly
the other method is to lock up the
actual physical asset and here we have I
mean it that's more costly because
you're going to be using um physical
entities to to to do this but the
capital efficiency is much greater
because you can release the funds
immediately upon Lo
come okay thank you all right um why is
this a good thing why are we sort of
excited about this idea of a sort of
Step change in economic Evolution and
the question we sort of want to address
here is what is the argument for why we
might expect that hockey stick just to
keep going up like what is the what what
is the argument for why we would expect
to see further and further growth and
you know the the counterargument here is
well you know limited resources in
finite planet and you know post
capitalism and you know it can't keep
growing forever
but the claim here is it could and not
in the sense of you know more and more
resource intensity type of growth what
we're describing is not economic growth
what we're describing is economic
evolution in the sense that the
fundamental coordinating mechanisms of
an economy just get better and better in
terms of processing distributed
information and this is a sort of
crucial Insight is that you ask what are
what is an economy um an economy is a
way that a bunch of humans come together
and create resources and and and and and
provision each other um you know we use
it for making stuff and doing stuff but
we also use economies for organizing and
growing knowledge um economies are the
basic mechanism by which we organize our
resources for Innovation and our
resources for um you know protection of
environment and just all of the things
that we want to do collectively and that
notion of economies as coordination
mechanisms is the key thing we want to
sort of emphasize here that what just
happen happened with the sort of digital
crypto distributed computable economy is
that we've got a step change in our
ability to coordinate our you know our
Collective actions together and that
that shift what does that mean it means
that we can start solving much harder
problems so industrial capitalism what
did it do um you know many things but
one of the main things that it sort of
did was it lifted a sort of medieval
Society you know particularly in one
part of of the world and then gradually
spread around the world out of poverty
it was a poverty alleviation mechanism
that it's not complete it's got a long
way to go yet um it's caused some new
problems um in in that process around um
you know ecological sustainability but
it was a mechanism that enabled you know
a group of humans that got bigger and
bigger and bigger to solve some
fundamental problems economies are
knowledge solving mechanisms um what we
can start to do now if if we can if we
can
if we can sort of digitally connect all
of the things in the world bring them
online um enable them to become visible
to to a mechanism we can start to solve
a lot harder problems so challenges
around um dealing with externalities a
sort of the climate change problem a lot
of ecological problems you know a lot of
just fundamental things that we're
currently relying on governments to do
or trying to sort of re-engineer human
belief systems and so on we're using
cultural mechanisms or political
mechanisms to solve which you know we're
making some progress r with that but
it's not um it's nothing compared to the
to the power of sort of being able to
harness economic mechanisms to solve
that so one of the sort of you know the
reason that we see this this sort of
optimistic sort of argument about why
this Curve will continue to rise not
because of you know economies keep
growing forever but economies evolve to
take on and start to solve much much
harder and and deeper problems so um
problems around um internalizing
externalities um classic eological type
problems
um Step changes in in Innovation um
particularly around sort of a lot of
biomedical type problems um and
opportunities just that ability to bring
more and more resources to connect sort
of capital around the world into sort of
taking these these things on where at
the moment the only mechanism we really
have for doing that are either large
corporations or or governments or
various sort of coalitions on that again
it's kind of an okay solution it sort of
works sometimes but it's nowhere near as
powerful as it could be and it's this
it's this sort of argument that the more
we can do this the more we can sort of
drive real world assets on chain um the
more sort of we can we can start to
bring just information from all you know
from a full stack of information onto
sort of trying to sort of solve these
types of problems so that's the argument
for for why a computable economy is is
good um why this is something sort of
aspirational that we want to work
towards um why the sort of next sort of
continuation of that hockey stick isn't
isn't more and more industrial growth or
or post capitalist growth it's using
global economic systems to solve even
harder and more General sort of problems
so that's that's where we find ourselves
um that's why we're sort of excited
about this this this direction of of
what what this type of institutional
Revolution toward um computable
economies can bring thank you all right
that's awesome let's go to the Q&A
session guys so please scan the QR code
here and and ask the question is going
to pop up on the
screen and you guys here we go let's
fast go to let's go for the first
one who want to answer I'll take that
one thank you um so the sort of
Economics that we're dealing with here
um is not traditional sort of
neoclassical economics um the the the
reason for that is that what we're sort
of driving to is is is far more um
instit tional economics information
economics um mechanism design and trying
to sort
of understand what we can do with that
as a um to design sort of global
internet-based digital economic systems
where what we're fundamentally engaged
in right now is this new opportunity to
essentially design Economic Institutions
from scratch um these need to be
integrated with economies as they
currently exist we'll use a lot of
Institutions that that we've had from
industrial economies to carry over for
that but there's an enormous opportunity
here to to just massively increase this
the scale and scope of things that are
in the economy and the first step to
that is basically um identification
attaching data to these things enableing
to be bought online that process of
bringing um much more of the stuff in
the world the stuff that we care about
and want to organize and try and sort of
Shepherd and so on um in into the
economy so industrial economies did that
in a big way from from feudalism to sort
of modern capitalism that was a 600 year
old process of bringing a bunch of stuff
into into the economies um turning it
into Capital but a bunch of stuff got
left out of that um and critically envir
a lot of resources a lot of sort of um
problems that we we a lot of sort of
factors of production weren't sort of
part of that so I think you know there's
a there's a new opportunity here us to
create a new type of Economics so you
know we've called it computable
economics for a computable economy
um but that's the that's the sort of
challenge that we're trying to we're
trying to meet here all right we have
like one extra minute for you guys to
answer the question so don't don't be
too rushed we have time all right let's
go to the second question which one you
want to answer first um yeah I can
definitely put the the presentation uh
online I'll uh put it on the boson
protocol website so boson
protocol. um we'll have that up later
today yeah all right uh is the
presentation is publicly available for
people yes all right cool let me Mark
that up let's go to the uh the third
yeah the can you elaborate
that
more there was one just up here as well
was that yeah which one you want to
answer you can you can pick any
yeah what was the one pre yeah this one
can we ask that one can you uh scroll
down a little bit that oh just the one
above the presentation
yeah um okay
so so this yeah I mean this is um one of
the core challenges of tokenizing a
physical asset and um so it's this kind
of physical asset Oracle problem so that
as I mentioned in the presentation there
are kind of three ways three main ways
of ensuring that you know you can have
some control over a physical asset one
of them is to use a
centralized um sort of system and trust
that that centralized um intermediary
but that kind of um well it does it
doesn't unlock computable economies and
um is is is very much just you know
using the the current methods so aside
from that you have you have two um two
ways of doing it one is you can lock up
the funds um you know within a protocol
and the second is that you can use a a
trusted um uh verifier and custodian uh
to to lock up the actual physical asset
um and and in that case um you know the
protocol would still control who the
custodian releases the asset too um and
and so those are the two main ways of of
of um enabling this for physical assets
yeah let let's do the last question here
which one you want to
answer um the financial ization of
everything that's an interesting point
so I don't see this at all as
financialization of of of the world what
I see it as is the um computition of of
the world what we're trying to do is to
bring all of the you know anything that
we want to be part of of of an economy
which means things that we want to
organize and coordinate things that we
value and want to organize and
coordinate and to bring them into an
economy the standard way you do that is
with property rights or just you know
attaching ownership and ident and prices
and so on into something one of the
things that can go wrong with that is it
becomes financialized and becomes a
speculative object but the reason that
you're wanting to do that in the first
place is because you you care about
something and and you want that
information in a in a system to
coordinate um the the flip side of
financialization is basically
politicization um if if when there are
things and parts of of a of an ecosystem
and a global economy and so on that
aren't part of the economy externalities
what happens is that we have to use a
different mechanism for coordinating
them that mechanism is usually politics
um sometimes that works great if we have
you know high quality politicians and
everyone votes rationally and you know
we have a we have a you know a
legitimate institutional process that to
produce only good political outcomes
that system really can work um it's just
it doesn't always work like that and not
all countries have have have have that
sort of State um so this idea of sort of
trying to bring in um things that
currently sort of aren't part of the
economy to turn them into part of the
economy through a process of of you know
attaching of sort of capitalizing them
or attaching asset or attaching identity
to them enables them to be computed by
the economy it enables them to be
efficiently rationally allocated um to
find sort of the best re uses for them
so um you know now financialization is a
risk of that but politicization is the
sort of counter risk that we're sort of
trying to sort of meet against that's
awesome that's awesome PE get R Applause
to the speaker guys and the next session
coming at 5:30 yeah
[Music]
spe spee foreign
spe speech speech
[Music]
let
T let's go we come to the fifth set
session of the uh de coner stat six uh
the session is going to be about the
keynote the next 10 years of web three
in Africa the speaker is Joseph A please
welcome the
speaker oops sorry
[Music]
sorry hello everyone good to see you all
today uh I want to start off by asking
who is here from the continent of Africa
can you please raise your hand can you
guys please stand up can you guys please
stand up let's give this guys a big run
of Applause cuz like many of our folks
have gone through crazy lengths to get
themselves here with visas and
everything and this is the Defcon that
has the largest uh African Builder
concentration in one place um and my
talk today is around what can we expect
over the next 10 years in terms of
crypto Innovation and is very much
inspired by a lot of what I have learned
from all these folks and many more of
what are the things that are been built
today and what can we expect coming up
so two years ago at Defcon we
established the fact that it's actually
the crypto ecosystem that needs Africa
to reach its full potential of reaching
Mass adoption and utility driven
building to scale it to billions of
people and we covered the fact that we
are the most populous part of the world
and we're growing really fast that is
going to be where all the young people
in the world are going to be based at
even today we have about 600 million
Africans who are the under the age of 14
that's out of 1.5 billion people and we
also discussed around the technology
rails that exist that have allowed us to
basically skip generations of innovation
such as mobile phones skipping landlines
or mobile money where that has close to
a trillion bill trillion dollars worth
of transactions a year um and we're
jumping traditional banking with
crypto um two years ago when we
discussed a lot of this what was the
reality is that mostly many of us were
doing crypto toat transactions doing
payments savings and storing resources
or investing using predominantly
centralized exchanges and a lot of
centralized exchanges are actually not
made to be Banks they're trading
platforms but we kind of figured a way
to do that by having various liquidity
providers like people like you and I
providing liquidity on peer-to-peer
exchanges to drive a lot of a lot of the
value for normal people to access
traditional forms of banking that we
need so where are we today two years
from from then well the one reality is
that in the traditional World we're
still in the same place that we are
communicating value
over walls that the internet as amazing
at it's been at connecting us and
letting communication flow communication
of value which is through monetary
systems are actually very much gated the
internet continues to be very gated the
same way back in the days you would have
an operator basically connecting two
calls by manually calling the other side
and seeing can we trust the other
operator that's the same process that we
have today so we are still still working
through walls in the traditional
system the other aspect of where we
still are today is that a huge part of
our economy is happening in the informal
sector that includes our GDP of like our
predominant GDP is backed by uh uh
microenterprises uh a huge part of our
employment is in the informal economy a
huge part of our GDP is also drived uh
by by the informal economy and also a
lot of our money movement happens
outside of the banking system this is a
very important context for us to
understand why crypto is thriving so
much on the
continent another big also lens is that
we have a systemic US dollar problem
some of these numbers are a bit outdated
but we're importing more than what what
we're exporting we're taking a lot of
debt a lot of African countries debt has
doubled in the last 10 years and we're
paying that debt plus interest in
dollars and we're trading with each
other as neighbors using dollars um and
when our currencies fluctuate so much
then we move our money to dollars so
that creates a demand Supply and and and
on the uh supply pressure we have a lot
of exports remittance people sending
money there's a thing called brick some
of you guys might know about it around
some countries deciding to settle
outside of the dollar system which is
creating a bit less pressure on the
dollar and there's a lot of Aid and
loans for the coming do dollars so what
is the consequence of this is that
basically the US dollars are being
rationed by the central banks the demand
for dollars is higher than what they
have there so what you end up having is
the bifurcation of the bank rate and the
black market rate or how I call it the
actual market rate um and in worst
economies you see that being very large
in well-managed economies it's very
small but we're living in in parallel
systems and also that makes the dollar a
commodity so people do unnatural things
in order to access dollar dollars
because the upside on trading the dollar
is higher than the the trade on the
commodity itself which creates very you
know weird dysfunctions in in in our in
our system um and some countries have
also created rules of how who can own
dollars and how much you can transfer it
until very recently the Ethiopian
government actually made it illegal
meaning you can go to prison for it for
holding more than $500 with you at any
given point many of my friends and
family's houses were raid just people
looking for dollars and that's because
the central banks don't have enough
dollars and what that means we borrow
more money and then just rinse and
repeat so we have a systemic dollar
problem and so you look at that and say
okay well what is crypto doing well
fundamentally what crypto has provided
us is basically a digital version of the
dollar US dollar stable coins that allow
for large scale liquidity coordination
mechanism in the informal economy where
a lot of have been circulating
physically or through uh various
networks like the haa networks that call
each other and basically move numbers
around what do that has allowed us is
basically for early stage startups to be
able to aggregate more liquidity than
what a bank can in a very short period
of time and then settle that payment in
a much shorter period of time and this
has been a fundamental value proposition
of crypto so as a result of that crypto
has been thriving it's been growing even
in the bare Market crypto transactions
have been growing in on the continent
Chen alysis says we've had 125 billion
worth of transaction last year when I
talked to the analyst and the builders
it's that's just the tip of the iceberg
there's there's much more dollar that's
been transacted be behind that Nigeria
of course is the second most uh popular
place for crypto and Nigeria Ethiopia
Kenya we search crypto on online because
it is solving fundamental problems for
for us and so but this is not just
centralized exchanges this is happening
in other rails that have been built so
actually some of the builders here in
this room have built some of these
stacks these are from the builders in
magma from wallet infrastructure so
actually making like SDK wallets that
you can embed into your fintech
application or your crypto application
so you can use crypto and Fiat
aggregating liquidity onchain and
offchain which is actually not very easy
to do
and and simplify the on andof run
process through that different types of
wallets that are being created um and
all types of payments from B2B b2c B2 B
Toc serving like small businesses medium
large mediumsized businesses oil and gas
companies and even Banks and payment
service providers who are now using
these startups to facilitate
International payments and people even
issuing debit cards on top of your
digital wallet in order to be able to
pay online without having any
limitations because some of our banks
say I'm so sorry you can only pay $10 a
month well if you have some resource you
want to buy a book from Amazon how can
you buy it with $10 Amazon is more
expensive than that so you you're
actually using crypto projects in order
to do that and so some of these projects
are like way advanced than where I see a
lot of on andof Rams and so bluntly
speaking if Devcon was h
in one of the countries that were
mentioned in Africa the Defcon
organizing team can pay all their bills
using crypto all of us would basically
be using our crypto to make payments
with Fiat without even needing a Fiat
wallet paying directly just using the
applications that have been built today
so there's been a lot of work that has
happened in terms of making the user
experience a lot easier and if you're
curious about it just talk to many of
the builders who are in this room
so with that in mind what can we expect
in the next 10 years what are some of
the innovations that we can expect to
have well fundamentally I think the most
interesting part of crypto to me is
bringing whole economies empowering them
by a decentralized systems part of that
is basically changing the foundations of
our existing economy and part of it is
like opening up new economic activities
that we did not know existed before um
and this is where I think ethereum comes
in because that's the most robust and
the most resilient decentralized system
that we have right now so it's a it's
it's a beautiful merge
here and when we think about rewriting a
lot of the foundations of our economies
we got to think about both hyper
globalization and Hyper localization we
talked a lot about US dollar stable
coins right so the answer is not let's
dollarize the entire African economy
everyone uses dollars dollars for
everyone that's not the answer I don't
think that helps us and it doesn't help
the global economy so we got to also
think very locally and one idea I'd love
to dive deeper on is this idea of
actually local currency stable coins at
the moment when we think about stable
coins it's kind of synonymous with US
dollar stable coins how about actually
having our Kenyan Nigerian Shillings
Kenyan shillings Nigerian NAA Ethiopian
bur a lot of our local currencies having
a digital version of them onchain what
does that allow well onchain Forex that
makes it a lot more efficient we'll
double click on that cheaper local
payments in a crazy way today with blobs
it is cheaper to run uh transactions on
a layer two at least four five to 10
times than it is on mobile money or
banking which is quite crazy well that
doesn't mean blobs will scale infinitely
but it's just an interesting data point
of what we can even do today and the
last part of the value here that we can
think of at this stage is that it gives
us programmable money and that opens up
a whole lot of opportunities and
innovations that can happen I really
want to double click on the onchain
Forex well today Kenya and Tanzania are
neighboring countries right next to each
other we even speak similar languages
and both our currencies are called
Shillings but in order to make a payment
from Kenya to Tanzania you actually have
to convert it to the dollar dollar has
to go through the sft system it has to
floor through London or New York or
somewhere it can take a few days and
depending on the volume it can take even
weeks it's a very long process and long
system it's it's it's it doesn't make
sense that we're having to do this as
neighbors right with local stable coins
you could potentially move from the
Kenyan Shilling stable coin to a
Tanzanian Shing stable coin both
denominating in value against the dollar
but not actually touching the dollar so
this helps us move the US dollar from
just being a medium of exchange to being
a unit of account which is a very
interesting use case for it
so one way that can work is pre building
a pair of of liquidity where some an
importer is putting money uh into the
the pool from the Kenyan side and Export
is pulling money out of it and the
person does the exact same thing on the
Tanzanian front and because every trade
ises not fully Balan you use dollars to
basically rebalance the pool by adding
local currency on the other side this is
just one model I'm sure we can come up
with way multip way more complex and
more interesting models to structure
this but bringing Forex on chain is one
of the most interesting problems for us
to solve using local stable coins now
when we think about that we can think
you know in a few million dollar value
or we can think about half
economies and I think the most important
thing that we keep missing in the space
when we like look at the full potential
of crypto is that we're not always
looking at like how can have an economy
run on what we're building and what
needs to be true for us to get there and
the reason why I'm saying that is
because you know many of you know Essa
right Essa is one of the best success
stories that has come out of Kenya half
the Kenyan economy runs on impesa what
empa is is just a private Ledger it's a
spreadsheet where this they put some
Fiat in the bank and the numbers move
from different account names and at the
end of the day it's basically settled at
the bank layer that's somehow of version
of what we're talking about but what
we're talking about is putting that on
chain in a much more open transparent
system right for us to get to that level
of scale at a much faster period we got
to think about from different principles
and and one lens that I can think of is
using government bonds to back our local
stable coins you convert the local Bond
into a real world asset that can either
be coll fully collateralized through a
CDP or a better model that we can come
up with and by the way if you do a lot
to chat with you um and basically use
that to uh distribute local currency
through existing and new rails around
the Forex on chain is one of the much
like lowest hanging fruit examples of
where we can go but we can bring so many
other values to that and in the future
it doesn't just need to be uh government
bonds to do this we can bring other
types of assets like local land
productive land or protected land or
gold and silver and precious Metals
we're generating so much of that from
Africa at the moment or we can do other
types of Commodities like this is such
an open book in terms of what we back
our local currencies
with another pillar after local civil
coins that I love to chat about is
simple Finance as a stack now here in
the ethereum world we talk about
decentralization a lot well for us on
the continent decentralization is is
actually a very practical solution to a
very practical
problem we have a lot of banking rails
to build for hundreds of millions of
people and many of them have not been
born
yet to do that trying to build that in a
monolithic way as a centralized company
as one piece like alipe or witchat or
grab for 54 jurisdictions and scale that
in a very short period of time is almost
impossible to execute so the best way
for us to do that in my view is just to
build a connected web of
tools different pieces of the Lego that
form a financial stack that come
together that offer users a better
experience and better options right I
think building this in a much more
decentralized way it to me is like the
only way we can get to the level of
scale that we need to achieve so for us
it's actually a very practical solution
a practical way of getting there and we
can build interoperable monies with
network effects remember the walls the
operator we can just bypass that and
keep moving value across different
populations and people in that way
create cash apps with simple user
experience powered by crypto but we
don't even have to know that it's crypto
today we have startups that are doing
that but we can scale that to
infinity and on the hyper localization
lens um there are many ways we can build
around existing trust structures across
many African countries we have basically
cooperatives and look little communities
of people we call some of them some of
us call them table banking some some of
us called them Chamas where basically
people pull money together to save and
lend to each other there's a strong
trust infrastructure that exists to
enable things like that we don't have to
reinvent Trust From Scratch we can
leverage those existing trust structures
to build very resilient hyper local
economies and I think that should be
part of our road map
and Beyond you know so ultimately it's
just two people or two companies or two
agents having normal Financial
transactions right no complexity not
much we're not talking about crypto at
the front end this is all enabling that
other areas of innovation that we can
think about is like around credentialing
identity reputation credit
scoring building bringing things that
don't exist on chain to create Trust on
chain is are some of the more
interesting areas for us to experiment
on we don't have time to dive deep into
many of these and there's a lot more
than other areas of innovation that we
can build in the next 10 years but talk
to the builders around the table um and
the other area bringing assets on chain
such as real estate we talked about
bonds earlier but different types of
Commodities Energy power generating uh
structures that we need to fund and and
then are actually Revenue generating we
can experiment with so many of these
that actually Powers the fundamentals of
our
economies so with all these ideas and
directions that we can go you might be
wondering how do I help how do I connect
how do I participate in this well the
first is uh it's an invitation It's
actually an invitation because there's
there's a lot of building happening on
the
continent whether we have a lot of
Builders coming to Defcon or not so it's
an invitation for you all from
infrastructure from research from
different ecosystems and chains from
Capital allocation from mentorship and
support from actually like working with
some of the smartest people on the
planet there are many ways you can plug
in into the movement that is happening
in
Africa and of course why not bring
Defcon to Africa in two years
time who Who's down for something like
that here right well yeah I think
that'll be super cool and you guess
will'll have a blast joining Devcon
there but but it's actually not about
having another big event on the
continent it's actually it gives you a
much deeper context to go and see this
in practice it is very very hard to
explain how broken the world Gardens are
until you actually go and experience it
in person or is very hard for me to
explain to you like what seamless e
experience for crypto looks like without
actually going and experiencing and
making a whole lot of payments and
living your life using your crypto
wallet without touching physical bills
right so it's an invitation for you to
actually be part of the movement and
work that that we have and lastly
because all the ethereum events that
have happened around the world have
happened in places where it's just very
hard to get visas right so to get 177
folks here man that was like a lot of
work and it's been a lot of collective
effort and there are hundreds and
thousands more that you would absolutely
enjoy connecting with and learning with
and learning from
and so you're invited home welcome
guys all right that was awesome
presentation you guys we have this a Q&A
session so anyone want to put question
that's a QR right there just scan it and
put a question there we have a lot for
you brother yes let's take a look which
you want to answer first uh we can talk
about the non-financial use cases we
talked about them later on yeah this
stock focused a lot on finance because
it's just a lot to unpack and each topic
that we talked around credentialing
around bringing assets on chain uh and
credit scoring and like gaming and
communication there's like there's a lot
to unpack there um I will actually
invite you guys to talk to some of our
Builders here to understand a lot of the
nuances but I mean at the moment like
500 million Africans don't have any form
of legal ID right and the best that some
of our countries are doing is basically
having a a data center in one location
or two location and putting the entire
population's data there it's like a
honey pod of sovereign data right that's
not the most secure way to do it in my
opinion so I think there's a lot of ways
we can innovate around that kyc is one
that really came up like transferable
kyc across multiple tools um so the list
goes on so the invitation is to actually
talk to the builders in the
room any question you want to answer we
have a lot more here right uh what do
you see Africa becoming
what do you see Africa becoming a well
coordinated road map yeah I want to talk
about regulation all right let's go
because that's that continues to be a
Hot Topic and it's really important to
us because many of our Innovations are
interfacing the traditional world with
the crypto world because that that door
needs to be very fluid it needs to allow
money to keep moving back and forth for
a long period of time and until we bring
it on chain um and I think that's a
that's a very important problem so I
talked to a bunch of regulators many of
the builders here talk to many
Regulators there's there's some
curiosity there's some fear because
crypto can be a path for Capital flight
a lot of value to live in a short period
of time right and that's a that's an
actual risk um and some of them don't
even understand the fundamentals of this
technology so what we end up having is
some countries like South Africa saying
crypto is legal it's a commodity we will
allow it and so we have a lot of
Builders working there some countries
creating uh um uh
uh environments for experimentation like
sandboxes uh and actually um this is a
bit of a controversial view but I think
creating some sort of tax revenue from
crypto transactions for governments is a
is a potentially positive thing if it's
done well because it moves this category
from a a risk basis to an income
generating category um and bringing
local stable coins on chain is I think
one of the big biggest value props for
governments because what it does is it
creates a much more efficient Capital
markets for dollars and bonds it brings
dollars in and it helps reduce the
dollar pressure for local trade that can
happen so they have an incentive to see
something like that but there's a lot of
people here doing the hard work of
actually informing regulators and we
keep building like we keep building even
with gray area we keep building like the
show doesn't stop um and I think that's
something some of us in like the Western
World find it hard to kind of navigate
around is because like even when Nigeria
makes crypto
illegal like we still have close to 15%
of the countes GDP like proportion
transactions happening in crypto right
so yeah it makes you kind of Wonder um
like what what what some of those kind
of guidelines can can actually have an
effect I think we have about one or two
question more let's let's see what we
want to answer
am I hiring are you
hiring uh I mean the I I don't know
guys uh we can jam outside after this
and uh recruit more more folks to help
answer the question but yeah I guess
like what needs to happen before a
Defcon happens there is like there's a
lot we got to do on the continent we
have many communities doing real work uh
they need a lot of support and
engagement so I think that will bring a
lot of value we need to have more
hackathons and Builders but like I think
our Builder Community like the startups
that we have there are from a user
experience perspective in my opinion are
like way ahead from what we keep talking
about around usability making crypto
usable for daily life um like whenever
I'm in many African countries like I
don't use my card I don't use cash I'm
just like paying all types of bills
using my crypto account um and I think I
think that's super cool and that's
amazing so like even the Builder
Community alone is enough uh to host you
all all right give Applause for the
speaker thank you so much and the next
session going to come at 6:00 stay tuned
[Applause]
[Music]
and now
test test test
test
testest
test test okay anyone lost a hotel Key
we keep it for you here if found the L
61 so want lost the hotel Key come to
see the star in the front thank you guys
[Music]
spe
m
[Music]
you
am
[Music]
I
all right here we come to the last
session of the state six today and the
topic is decentralized economic
opportunities communities using crypto
and decentralized protocols to make
local economic impact in Brazil Nigeria
and Kenya please welcome Jambi J and
Arna Stone please guy
[Music]
hello
everyone Hi
everyone stick around because that was
really the perfect introduction for our
talk in a wider framing for how
decentralized currencies are actually
being put to work in different emerging
economies
um I'm really excited to talk to you
about how we're using the free
permission distribution of money to
really impact people on the ground and
Last Mile community commities that are
currently underserved by traditional
Financial
systems
uh I am here as the executive director
of a project called good dollar good
dollar is a universal basic income
protocol whose mission is actually to
enable anyone with access to a
smartphone with a cell phone to be able
to access decentralized currencies and
actually onboard into crypto we do this
through Distributing a digital Universal
based basic income every day and that's
helped us onboard nearly a million
people I am thrilled to be joined here
today with johie Jorge who is the
director of Grassroots economics which
is I would say probably one of the
leading projects if not the leading
projects that's actually innovating with
decentralized currencies and really
breaking the Monopoly on money in terms
of helping communities to create more
credit more Commerce bottom up through
using decentralized tooling and it's a
great example of ethereum in the real
world uh I will say that I've been
building this space for a long time and
it makes me very excited to see the talk
that came before if you will that really
shows that this progress is happening at
scale and Jambi is I'd say the zoom in
the double click in as to the framing
that we just saw so some of you guys
might have seen crypto is useless
um some of you guys might have seen this
Tok to yesterday or seen some people
walking around with a crypto is useless
hat and the idea here is actually a very
clever campaign out of C which is that
crypto is useless unless you've had a
real need to use
it and the meta framing for all of this
is that there are still 1.7 billion
people around the world who are living
in countries where inflation out paches
wages if the past few years have been
any indication that's going to continue
to increase there are 1.4 billion adults
around the world that remain unbanked
that means people who have no access to
any of the financial services that yosf
just mentioned in terms of savings
payments credit Etc uh most of this 1.4
billion people have access to a very
magic computer that they carry around in
their phones which is a smartphone and
that's what enables them to access the
same ethereum virtual machine that we
all use as and so there's the 6.17
million crypto owners today represents a
big gap to close in terms of where
crypto still has its biggest potential
to make a real impact on the financial
lives of billions around the
globe we're here to talk about
decentralized economic opportuni so what
are some of the principles that we're
looking at uh the first is
permissionless access so how are we
actually removing
Gatekeepers uh crypto is the most
obvious example of that anyone can sign
up for a web 3 wallet anyone can send or
receive currency it is this
permissionless that actually
enables local gra local empowerment to
happen uh bottom up where communities
are able to grow in their own Super
Cycle if you will and ultimately this is
designed to drive resiliency and
adaptability for economies that uh where
it doesn't really make sense that the
global macroeconomic shocks of say the
US presidential election have such a big
effect on Last Mile Farmers or
communities all around the world and so
this is designed to actually increase
resilience so that there's less of a
single point of failure for individuals
and
communities the reality is is that still
today it's places where capital is
needed the most that capital is the most
expensive
this comes as no surprise to anyone here
from The Real World ethereum track but
in Nigeria just for
context for a 100 to $1,000 loan you're
looking at an annualized interest rate
from anywhere from 30 to 50% right so if
you're actually looking to start a small
business it means that money is at more
expensive for you than it is for many of
us from the United States or from
Europe and the user experience has also
kept
um crypto adoption from happening for a
number of reasons right so up until very
very recently it's been very hard to
access web 3 in terms of sign the sign
up process for a wallet certainly if
you're don't have access to a bank
account it's not that simple to go
online and buy a $100 of Bitcoin on some
on
binance all of this results in there
being a very high cost of
experimentation for individuals and this
is what creates this narrative around
crypto being useless right is that uh it
without with all these challenges facing
the space it's hard to build products
that seem like they're of real
use however in 2024 we're facing a new
reality where not all of our problems
have been solved but certainly the
potential exists to make a massive
change we see that there are a number of
Simple Mobile native Solutions there are
over a 100 million stable coin holders
around the world this has probably been
seen as the one of the key uh killer use
cases of crypto today and this is
creates the preconditions for us to
really begin to build for real
communities and real needs all of this
is critical because everything happening
on chain everything happening
transparently actually improves our odds
for financial access because it enables
individuals and communities to really
build credit history in a transparent
way as we just discussed it's actually
lower middle inome countries that are
driving crypto adoption today so India
Nigeria Indonesia are the fastest
growing crypto markets and 15 of the 20
fastest growing markets come from
lowincome
countries and unsurprisingly it's
decentralized systems and currencies
that are leading the way this is most
likely because of LeapFrog Innovation
which was referenced before where when
there's no pre-existing technology to
overcome people just NE jump directly to
the Next
Generation and so so Grassroots
economics which has been building in
this space for a long time I consider
one of the flagship LeapFrog Innovations
in the space because they're innovating
both on the payment rails and fintech
level but most importantly on the
currency and the monetary level in terms
of and really breaking the Monopoly on
money and how communities can create
their own value create their own credit
worthiness and actually expand the
amount of economic activity that they're
doing within the community this is a
this is where crypto has its biggest
potential and it's my true pleasure to
introduce jbi jorg who has been building
this and implementing this on the ground
for H for actually nearly 100
communities and she's flown here today
to tell us from Kenya to tell us about
her work and some of the impact that
it's had on their communities thank you
Anna
yeah my name is jambin jog I have been
working for grass economics foundation
for the last six years and I'm really
happy to be here I am an advocate for
Community inclusion currencies for
poverty education and sustainable
development
so how do we heal a postcolonial legacy
of ton communities and
ecosystem how do we enable communities
to create scale and scale credit how
does this enable wealth creation to stay
within the communities
this commitment pulling we've been
working on um commitment pooling which
is an economic protocol inspired by
indigenous wisdom so when I talk about
indigenous wisdom I I mean rotation of
Labor Association I come from the Kiku
community in Kenya and we call it muia
we have so many communities in Kenya
with very different names for this um um
indigenous uh practice and it's not just
in Kenya it's even Global um what you're
looking at the pictures here the first
one is a type of a rotation of Labor an
educational kind of it that is a service
mua women grinding uh maze for FL that
is an infrastructural kind of M there's
so many
okay um so um this is the difference of
what was and what is now so what was the
shared economic Commons you know the we
had synergetic commitments harmonious
flows accountable systems you know EOS
system regeneration Democratic stewards
unlike what we have now you know the fat
dominance open markets
ATC now in communities right now they
have these six assets for them to
understand they have the six assets and
to understand at what level these assets
are is very important and that is what
you're doing with communities now and
what this this uh image here is them
realizing that they have it like I have
what you don't have and you can benefit
from one another creating that we ISS
really visualizing what they can and
what they have um to offer one another
now I was talking about rotation of
Labor associations so this is all about
making commitments fulfilling
commitments and accepting commitments so
just to explain rotation of Labor in a
bit this is family one family two and
family three they all the families have
needs you know they they need a house
built they need a farm h fixed you know
so what they do they create commitments
backed by um they create um commitments
and then they say okay fine I'm
committing I will come and help build a
house for family one I'm also committing
that I will also help family two build a
house and eventually um they pull their
commitments together okay so those are
pulls commitments so that means I when I
make commitments I will accept
commitments and I will also fulfill
commitments so when they they all
fulfill commitments they are allowing
accountability and exchange um and they
they have a clear and non agreed upon
rules okay so um So eventually when they
do a cycle of helping one another you
know doing the commit giving commitments
accepting commitments and fulfilling
commitments there is a a range of
physical um assets grown social assets
grown human spiritual political and
natural assets you know they change now
grassroot economics Foundation has been
helping formalize these commitments uh
by adding technology and now it becomes
easier for me to Value what I'm offering
um in a community H it's easier because
they have an unique signature H there is
an expiration date uh you can you can
decide to have a demor or not but a
demor is very important to help with the
circulation of the vouchers and then it
also means that whoever accepts um that
voucher has the right to redeem it from
the issue okay now making commitments
and fulfilling commitments and accepting
commitments is Paramount and this is
what used to happen and it's now um what
you're advocating for but trust is very
important this is how trust was grown
then this is a nice illustration we do a
lot of games and practicals when you go
when you're training communities and
this is how they understand the current
Reality by understanding the six asset
and at what level is which asset and
when they do this they're able to come
up with a vision and know how each
person um who each action step um will
be worked on according to the rotation
of Labor
associations now this is production
financing um this is also a very
important um protocol that you um
borrowed from um our forefathers um it
only means that um when the Comm
community members create vouchers they
put them into the pool
um and when a financial wants to get
some of the products that are backed by
these vouchers they will need to put in
money into the pool and pull out of
vouchers I'm going to give a good
example of a a financier who pre-ordered
coconuts from farmers in kifi so what
they did they put in money into the pool
and took the vouchers backed by the
Coconuts coconuts Take 5 to seven years
to grow so that means when so the
financial had um had the you know had
the money before prior and the vouchers
prior and the community members got the
money before so that means they were
able to sort out issues uh fees you know
better farming methods better tools so
we just basically uh bringing a nice
socioeconomic uh uh uh process you know
that is um about uh bringing together a
nice um blend of you know changing the
traditional demand and Supply models and
you know tokenize um
tokenization now this is what the
communities in Kenya are doing they're
using the ussd and they're also there
the also the web interface um so this is
mostly the web interface is mostly for
those who do not have um
smartphones um uh phones so they can
create their own paper wallet and they
can use one phone now we have so far
seen over 65 ,000 households using
vouchers in Kenya today we have 4
million plus um worth of transactions
USD worth and 5x average um multiply
effect so pulled commitments enable us
to scale into the future the um to our
beautiful shared Heritage thank
you thing and so um this came up in the
talk right before but it's actually how
do we use these systems rather to create
new trust but actually to unlock trust
that actually already exists on the
ground and this is what I've admired the
work that Grassroots and Jambi have been
doing for so many years now is actually
looking bottom up from the community
infrastructure and developing tooling
that actually enables those communities
to unlock and assess value in new
ways excitingly uh this is one example
of I believe thousands if not hundreds
of thousands that are happening around
the world in terms of communities that
are beginning to build circular
economies um using decentralized
currencies that actually enable people
to create their own value this is a
circular economy image from a community
in Brazil that has hundreds of women
that actually operate using uh the good
dollar token as a community store to buy
and sell
Services we also have uh great examples
of different entrepreneurs around the
world who are using decentralized
currencies bottom up to create airtime
shops enabling people to use crypto to
swap into Mobile minutes into airtime
swap airtime value which actually is a
basic need for anyone living in the
Contemporary
world and I think really critically the
reason why this is relevant and relevant
now is because now we start to compose
the full stack that actually enables
this to become practical and possible
and it involves
more than just technology right and so
what we see is that building the stock
bottom up from the technical aay what
makes it actually useful for real people
for the hundreds of people that JN and
Grassroots have touched is actually the
social element the community and
education element that actually brings
people along and customizes these
Technologies for their
needs so to bring it back crypto is
useful but it's most useful in an
ecosystem that has all of the different
components of the stack that make it
useful and so this suit that I'm wearing
is not just for fun it is fun though uh
it's to represent the idea of an
ecosystem and the value of an ecosystem
and that actually being the critical
enabling Lynch pin to uh making the real
world ethereum useful and I think
everyone at devc con who's made such an
expert effort to come here to actually
contribute to this ecosystem understands
that and the more localized ecosystems
that we develop the more we will see
this come
true uh so yes this is crypto today real
world ethereum is decentralizing
Economic Opportunity and I think we need
to stay passionate and stay focused
because this is still the biggest
upgrade to money since it went digital
we see decentralized economies actually
upgrading the money itself and it
enables money to flow back to the parts
of the economy that are otherwise deemed
unprofitable or non-profitable and this
is what Grassroots and other projects
are doing it actually enables the real
wealth to come back into Community
because in you know many communities
around the world the people are there
the resources are there the desire to
collaborate is there but what's actually
missing is money and so if we can
actually innovate on the money itself
through using the right tooling then we
are able to support the decentralization
of Economic Opportunity that we want
want to see
happen uh thank you very much for
listening and thank you to the ethereum
foundation for making this
possible all right awesome guys so again
Q&A session we have the QR code on a
screen scan it and send a question to
the screen so we can see what you have
burning question
here all right
guys let's see I think people just wait
a little bit people are still
scanning I think we have about a few
minute while we waiting for them to send
the question anything you want to say
add on a little bit
yeah yeah
just
yeah yeah um there's something else I
wanted to add like um for the the
pulling you know the E the production
financing uh page um when you put in
money people I community members can now
withdraw that you know offramp that via
valora um minip to through kotani uh one
ram phone bank into Kenya Shillings so
it's really been amazing and I would
also want to thank ethereum foundation
for making sure that um I got here yeah
thanks all right you have a
question all right do you my pass to my
one
second oh here's the question but but
let's uh hear from the ladies first okay
okay go ahead thanks for calling me lady
I'm not sure I identify that way but
sure um it's okay uh so Jey this is a
question for you what are the biggest
barriers that are still faced because
you've obviously had to overcome quite a
few to get the technology in place to
support these existing traditional
systems what are what are the barriers
that still exist if any in utilizing
technology in this
way yeah so one of the major barriers
that you've had to you know we still
even experienc right now is the network
connectivity in some of the rural areas
so they when they are trying to sort of
um exchange into the
swap um yeah so network connectivity in
some areas really is a challenge and we
we normally sometimes I have to force
them to go to the the nearest cyber cafe
or you know the nearest school cuz we're
assuming that is where they would get
like Network so movement challenges and
yeah I'll say that is like one of the
major and and really smartphones phones
in some rural areas so we've had to like
even give a group like one phone where
they need to like log out login using
the paper
wallets sure right we have three
question on the screen anything you want
to answer
first so um the first one how do we
quantify impact so now
um when I was talking about production
financing so what we do we borrow this
from um the past okay so in community
members uh in communities there were
leaders in each Community like Village
Elders they would sit and decide the
next um rotation of Labor um activities
so now we don't have staff at grass like
salaried staff so what we do we work
with um sewards and sewards are members
of the community so they are the ones
that handhold the community members so
whenever the communities are meeting for
rotation of Labor whatever it is that
they do is it building houses is it
building roads or teing Farms so they
send that as a report so what we do we
put in s dollar into the pool get their
vouchers so the vouchers in this case
are is backed by their commitments or
their m& services so when the report is
in then we pay them back using the
voucher so really the the trades um on
the sara. network platform um you know
represents the reports that they've sent
so these trades in in the eastern part
of Kenya equals to 10 houses 5
Etc all right that's awesome uh let's go
to the next one I think you have like
three minute two two question more yeah
yeah no no you take your
to I'm GNA address
the first two in one answer so how do
you actually deal with onboarding I'm
going to speak now from we gave money
away um from the perspective of good
dollar Ubi or free money has actually
proved to be an incredibly effective
onboarding method uh in terms of
bringing people into web 3 and I think
what's important about that is that we
see that that onboarding mechanism then
translates into people exploring a
deeper Financial life on chain um and so
obviously a good uxx simple onboarding
experience uh but actually
making you know assets free and
accessible and encouraging people to
experiment has been critical to
onboarding people retaining people and
encouraging their ability and desire to
experiment
um there was one other question but I
forgot oh was about creating trust
between local how can trust between
local communities in emerging countries
and the global crypto ecosystem can uh
be
unlocked so I think in in my experience
a lot of this is actually happening on
the local and the community level right
so it's through local community leaders
that create the relevant education and
and context for the individuals that
come along and or the individuals that
are also members of that community and
as Builders it's about having the
relevant on and off ramps and the
relevant tools that are specific to that
particular country and Country context
so I think that has actually proven to
be on and off ramps which come up all
the time and the
experience are the really critical
bridges in the actual user experience
when it goes from you know someone using
a very specific Local app or currency
such as Grassroots versus the cash out
experience AKA Fiat in my pocket Mobile
minutes on my phone uh ethereum in my
wallet all right anything uh three
obious question you want to answer we
have like one more minute if you want to
yeah um how do we deal with failures of
trust within a group like for our
experience as gradate economists we work
with already existing groups that have
their own Constitution and they know how
they deal with some of these challenges
so what what you're doing is just adding
technology to our practice that they
already know that has already been there
so most of the times the groups you know
follow what they know normally do even
without like amongst the commun is it
going to the chief is it going to the
Village Elder how do we sit down and um
um sort that out so mostly it's within
the
groups want to do one more if you have a
a short one we have a 30 second we can
do it if you want to
how yeah yeah go ahead
sure um how can initiatives be protected
from Bots it's a great question uh when
you're giving free money away it's
something that you have to confront and
deal with decentralized identity isn't
or decentralized secure unique identity
is not a new problem and there's
multiple ways to skin the cat I'd say
actually what makes me the most excited
now is like new solutions that are based
off of existing community and trust that
uh actually enable members of groups to
verify one another and verify the unique
identity of one another and I think this
is a space that many builders in
ethereum have been tackling for many
years and we're about to see a next
generation of solutions that are
actually much more usable for
individuals to verify one another and I
think that's how Bots will be dealt with
moving forward all right thank you you
guys so much and please give that
Applause to the speaker
[Music]
[Applause]
guys all right you guys this is the last
session for today and tomorrow we have
the first session at 9:45 on the state 6
so please enjoy Bangkok outside a lot of
good food there and you can have a good
night bye-bye
[Music]
m
is
[Music]
a
see
[Music]
oh e
oh
[Music]
e
e e
[Music]
for for
for
[Music]
e
e for